it's been over three years since the
last episode of game of thrones ended
and hbo has released the first in a
series of got related spin-offs house of
the dragon based off the book fire and
blood by george r.r martin for those of
you familiar with my channel you may
have seen my how game of thrones should
have ended video and how i wasn't too
pleased with how that series ended but
fans rejoice after watching the first
episode i think we're back on track and
i hope to god because i spent too much
damn time making this over-the-top
family tree for those of you worried
about book spoilers don't worry i'll
save that till the end of the video in
my spoiler section and i'll give you a
warning when that comes up there will be
some game of thrones show spoilers so
beware now we're going to take a huge
deep dive into the lore backdrop and
world of episode 1 including some of the
key differences from the book so saddle
up get yourself comfortable preferably
under a weirwood tree and maybe even
indulge in some chicken think i'll take
two chickens because things are about to
get bloody we descend into westeros just
a bit north of king's landing at
harrenhal a place you may remember from
game of thrones we get a brief history
lesson here voiced by none other than
rhaenyra targaryen judging by her tone
this is likely adult renera who we
haven't yet seen the show but she's been
all over the trailer so i don't really
consider that a spoiler the first
century of targaryen rule is coming to a
close and the current king jiharis is in
a predicament even though the man had a
whopping nine children all his male
heirs have died including balon
targaryen the father of king viserys who
will get to know a bit more of in a bit
balon died at the age of 44 of a burst
belly this was likely appendicitis so
jiharis wanting to avoid any unrest that
would be caused after his death and
knowing that his own health was waning
decided to convene a great council
comprised of thousands of lords from
around the realm this would determine
the next heir as martin says in fire and
blood no fewer than 14 claims were duly
examined and considered by the lord's
assemble but of these 14 there were
really only two names that stood a
chance viserys the eldest male
grandchild of jiharis and renise the
eldest female who actually is three
years older than viceros renis actually
has the better claim here if we're going
by traditional monarchical hierarchies
like the british monarchy for example
not only is she older than viserys but
her father also a son of jiharis was
older than viserys's father but because
renise is a woman the council opted for
the next male in line hence why renise
has the title the queen who never was
we'll actually see renises uncle borman
baratheon refer to her as this at the
tournament however in the show she calls
him her cousin it's possible this could
be a different bormond or a change they
made for the show so this sly jabba the
king calling renise the queen who never
was in front of the king is almost as if
borman's saying we know who really
should be on that throne and otto leans
into the king telling him that they can
cut out borman's tongue for saying such
a treasonous thing targaryen's strength
has been solidified largely through
their control of dragons at the time of
jiharis the first there are currently 10
and in episode 1 we get to see two
however there are much more than 10 that
we'll get to know over the course of the
season after the votes were counted by a
multitude of maesters viserys is
determined next in line with martin
stating though the maesters who tallied
the votes never revealed the actual
numbers it was said afterward that the
vote had been more than twenty to one
this is an important point the lords
from all over westeros did not want a
female on the iron throne by a 20 to 1
margin so keep that in mind when viserys
decides to go against over a hundred
years of tradition by naming rhaenyra
his successor at the end of the episode
in the background we can see viserys's
wife emma of house aaron viserys and
emma are cousins the targaryens as we
know kept many of their marriages within
the family with even brothers and
sisters marrying as was the case with
viserys's mother and father alyssa and
baylon you'll also notice emma pregnant
here this is likely one of the many
unsuccessful pregnancies she talks about
later in the episode and not rhaenyra
who you might imagine since rhaenyra
would have already been four years old
when this council convened in
ac by the way you'll see on my map here
years referred to as bc and ac bc refers
to before aegon's conquest the first
targaryen king and also viserys's great
great grandfather and that ac refers to
after his conquest it's kind of like rbc
80. with all this talk of heirs and
succession i guess it makes sense this
first episode is called the heirs of the
dragon but our little history lesson
comes with a warning as ranira a voice
over ends the only thing that could tear
down the house of the dragon was itself
we flash forward nine years into king
viserys the first reign and also get
this little title card to help situate
game of thrones fans to where we are in
the timeline the events we're about to
witness take place 172 years before the
death of the mad king aerys targaryen
who you may recall was killed by jaime
lannister giving him the moniker
kingslayer ares also happened to be
daenerys targaryen's father flying
through the air on the dragon psyrax is
young rhaenyra targaryen and i just
gotta say it feels so good to be back in
king's landing especially during this
decadent period of westerosi history of
course we can see the red keep but
something we didn't really see in the
wide shots of king's landing in game of
thrones is the domed structure known as
the dragonpit aptly named because that's
where the dragons live in fact we do get
to see the runes of the dragonpit in the
later seasons of game of thrones it
having fallen into disrepair because
until daenerys came along there were no
more dragons to take care of rhaenyra
dismounts her dragon where her friend
alison tie tower awaits alison in the
books is supposed to be roughly 10 years
older than renera but for the show
they've made them around the same age i
think this works quite well as it adds
to this loving sisterly friendship
they're developing we also get our first
look at sir harold westerling lord
commander of the kingsguard who keeps
watch over the princess they're quite
far from the keep as we get these
sweeping vistas showing just how far the
dragonpit is from it these dragon tamers
a job i wouldn't want speak high
valerian to cyrax something we'll also
see ranira and her uncle damon speak to
each other in it's kind of a dead
language used mainly amongst scholars
and nobles one of its most famous words
dracarus meaning dragonfire was used by
daenerys in game of thrones and which
we'll see rhaenyra use to command cyrax
to burn her mother and brother's funeral
pyre if any of you are interested you
can actually take lessons and learn how
to speak high valerian and become a
virgin like me the differences between
alison and rhaenyra stand out from the
moment we see them alison is more prim
and proper wearing a dress and obeys the
rules as we'll see during the scene in
which he helps rhaenyra study rhaenyra
on the other hand is more adventurous
brave and isn't afraid to stand up to
authority ripping out one of the pages
of their septa's book she'll even tell
her mother she'd rather serve the realm
as a knight riding into battle and glory
then rearing children the two appear to
be fantastic almost inseparable friends
making their way through the red keep
and the courtyard which you may remember
from game of thrones however this time
without that giant mural of westeros
queen cersei had painted you may even
recall this whining staircase which may
be the one that the mountain and gregor
clegane had in their epic final duel
rhaenyra cares deeply for her mother who
is any day set to give birth while this
scene does show how much rhaenyra and
emma care for one another it serves a
second purpose showcasing how this toxic
patriarchal system has forced women to
be nothing but child bearers where quote
the child bed is their battlefield it
will be interesting to see when and if
rhaenyra is queen i do know the answer
to that what she will do to change these
structures and which enemies she'll make
doing so we open on king viserys at a
meeting of the small council telling a
dirty joke it's a lighthearted affair
for a king whose rule has been one of
relative peace with no one daring to
stand up to the targaryens and their
dragons but it's cordless valerian who
sounds the alarm on some impending
danger corliss is the richest man in
westeros next to the king of course
having accumulated vast sums of wealth
by procuring lucrative trade routes and
his house's dominance of the seas that's
part of the reason he sits on the
council as a lord admiral and master of
ships he's also married to viserys's
cousin renise he warns of a man named
craigastrahar a prince admiral of the
triarchy ridding the stepstones of
pirate infestations something that could
disrupt the realm's trade routes the
triarchy is a group of three free city
states of mir lis and tyrosh who banded
together to drive volantis from the
disputed lands the king however isn't
too concerned and actually sees the
triarchy ridding the step zones of
pirates as a job well done we'll talk
about more of that in the spoiler
section comprising the rest of the small
council is otto hightower hand of the
king grand maester melos lord beesberry
master of coin and lionel strong master
of laws not present daemon targaryen
viserys's brother commander of the city
watch rhaenyra is also here as the
king's cupbearer allowing her to gain
valuable insight into how her father
conducts business as king something that
will be a valuable asset to her as queen
this whole scene allowing renera to
listen in conversation made me think of
game of thrones where arya pretending to
be a boy poured wine for tywin lannister
lord beesbury's concerns center around
his large investment in damon's overhaul
of the city guard they have all new
equipment and fancy gold cloaks although
daemon is loved by his men his style of
enforcement as we'll later see is bloody
as hell what's important to note here is
that it seems all these men have their
own interests and not necessarily the
king's own interests at heart there's a
lot of subtle politicking going on here
my favorite being when corliss denies a
wine being poured into his cup as silent
protestation for the king not heeding
his warnings but before we can delve
further into this the king wants to
focus on what he calls the heirs
tournament a grand tournament with
nobles from all around the realm to
celebrate the soon-to-be birth of his
son in the books this tournament occurs
in a maiden pool and was actually to
celebrate king viserys's ascension to
the throne not the birth of his son from
renera's perspective it seems all her
father cares about is having a son after
all it is his duty as king to provide a
male heir which has subsequently put
rhaenyra on the back burner and hindered
their relationship at the funeral of her
mother rhaenyra will say
she'll never be good enough for her
father because she is not a man
something which i think viserys aims to
rectify near the end of the episode sir
westerling brings rhaenyra to the throne
room where he's shocked to find daemon
sitting on the throne for westerling
this is tantamount to treason someone
who isn't king sitting on the throne but
rainier asked him to leave the two alone
you may have noticed that the throne
here looks a lot more intricate than it
did in game of thrones showrunner ryan
condell explains i wanted to make a
hybrid version that
was closer to something described in the
original book damon says to his niece in
high valeria no less that the throne
will one day be his he's also so
self-centered that he believes this big
tournament viserys is holding is for him
it is called the heirs tournament after
all and daemon is next in line however
the heir here is referring to viserys's
unborn son and talk about an ominous
line from damon who says
damon has brought his niece a valerian
steel necklace made from material like
his sword dark sister which we'll see
him use against his fight with sir
kristen cole valerian steel you'll
remember being one of a few materials
along with dragonglass that could
destroy whitewalkers as he puts the
necklace around her he takes it in
calling it beautiful but it's set in
such a way where we aren't sure if he's
referring to her or the necklace itself
more on that in the spoiler section
among the shade of a weirwood tree
allison helps rhaenyra study wherewood
trees were seen all throughout game of
thrones and possess supernatural
properties bran used one to see into the
past revealing jon snow's parentage
alison tests rhaenyra about the story of
princess nymeria which is an apt story
considering princess nymeria was
considered a beautiful strong-willed and
indomitable warrior queen something
rhaenyra strives to be even though
rhaenyra might want that she's become
complacent with her position in life
calling it comfortable viserys suffers
from a cut on his back that doesn't seem
to be healing a cut he sustained on the
iron throne he looks to be suffering
from an ailment that is slowly taking
over his body making the issue of
determining a successor ever the more
pressing otto tells the maester not to
disclose this to anyone if suspicion is
aroused that the king is in ill health
and has yet to name a successor it could
cause god knows how much chaos this
knowledge also brings with it a lot of
power allowing otto to set up his plans
for the future damon himself will later
tell the king that because otto is the
second in line for house hightower he
will seize power any way he can viserys
visits emma and just like in the books
you know that the two have a loving
relationship this is a king who cares
for his queen the same cannot be said
for all the kings who have sat on the
iron throne also this is going to change
it a bit emma tells viserys that
rhaenyra believes she is to have a
sister and that she would name it
visenya to which viserys says their
family already had of asenya that would
be the mother of king maegor the cruel
viserys tells her of a dream depicting
them having a boy wearing the crown of
aegon the first king dreams are
something viserys holds in high esteem
as we'll get to a very important one
near the end of the episode emma tells
viserys that this is their last chance
at children she's lost so many she can't
bear the thought of losing another not
to mention the toll that it's had on her
body she apologizes for failing him in
providing a male heir but hopefully this
new child will be their miracle as
commander of the city watch we see just
how demon plans to run things commanding
his men to slaughter criminals with no
real trial if this is how he runs this
small group of men what would he do with
the entire realm at his control in
damon's mind he's simply enforcing the
king's laws and with hundreds of nobles
descending upon king's landing for the
upcoming tournament he's ridding the
streets of criminals and doing his
brother a favor here we can start to see
some of the divides within the small
council corliss supports damon and his
strict rule while otto sees it as
overstepping his bound what i thought
was the most interesting back and forth
was this i agree
i just hope you don't have to maim half
of my city to achieve this
time will tell it's almost as if damon
knows he's going to disobey his brother
and that ultimately if he's ever in
charge won't rule like the weakling his
brother is otto and damon really hate
each other with otto eventually asking
why damon has been visiting pleasure
houses while his wife lady ray royce is
at runestone alone damon hated this
marriage it was arranged by his
grandmother queen alexane but damon
hated the veil of aaron where she was
from grew bored of it and over time
developed a deep resentment towards his
wife in the next scene we'll see him
with a woman named messaria this is the
woman he'll later bring on dragonback
after he was ordered by his brother to
go back to his wife it's the only time
we'll see damon's dragon karaxis in this
episode damon can't seem to climax it
seems the fact that king may replace him
as heir is cramping his style arguably
my favorite sequence in the first
episode is the heirs tournament knights
from noble houses from around the realm
have come to test their might in a
celebration welcoming viserys's new son
some of these houses you'll remember as
big players from game of thrones in this
shot here we can see from left to right
house bolton tyrell mallister corbray
hightower leford cole stark lannister
baratheon tully couldn't make out what
this one was and finally house tarly as
the king addresses the crowd we can see
him wearing old king jaharis crown
rhaenyra arrives and we also get our
first glimpse of lena and lesnar
valerian the son and daughter of corliss
and renis you'll also notice just how
opulent this tournament is compared to
the one we saw in season one game of
thrones this whole area was one of
extreme decadence compared to what we
see in thromes the first to get struck
down is a tarly we can tell by the house
sigil here you may remember samwell
tarly being a descendant of this house
alison and raniera trade scandalous
rumors about members of the court but
renera has her eyes on one night in
particular sir kristen cole who has been
decimating his opponents he's a handsome
knight who will play a larger role in
the future as prince damon gets his
choice on who to challenge first
choosing wayne hightower otto
hightower's son it's yet another way
damon likes to get under otto's skin to
further annoy otto he asks for his
daughter's laurel to give him good luck
in the fight and if that wasn't enough
when they do jost damon plays dirty
using his lance to hit the horse and
knock gwen off nice little touch that
lord of coinbeesbury here puts five
coins on damon winning one of the
maesters whispers something into otto's
ear likely something to do about emma
considering he'll then tell the king it
just goes to show you how much
information passes through otto before
it's given to the king becerris rushes
to his wife's aid but is confronted with
an unfathomable decision the baby has
breached and the pregnancy will likely
end up killing both mother and child
will he kill his own wife for the chance
to save his unborn child and just as the
tournament turns bloody so too does the
bedchamber it was just like emma said to
renera their battlefield is the child
bed as the pregnancy turns nasty so too
does the fighting renise reminds her
husband that these knights have seen
nothing compared to what happened when
king maegor rule king maegor was a
polyamorous king who had six wives and
was known as maegor the cruel for how he
dealt with aegon's rebellion in the
battle beneath the gods eye but that's a
story for a different video the
tournament culminates in a big battle
between sir kristen cole and prince
damon targaryen both men landing blows
on the joust and ultimately fighting on
foot in a contest of arms the fight here
is pretty faithful to the book with
kristin besting damon with his morning
star kristin asks damon to yield which
he does but he never says the word he
won't even accept kristen's hand to get
up just showing what a bad sport he
really is kristin asks for renera's
favor which she gladly gives this won't
be the last time we see these two
together the birth scene is arguably the
most horrific part of the first episode
with emma having no say in what's to
happen to her body and child viserys
without even telling her has her pinned
down and operated on i guess i should
take back saying they have a good
marriage while emma does not survive the
ordeal the baby does at least for a day
with viserys naming him after his father
balon members in the royal box are
slowly alerted to the news it's been a
bloody day both on and off the
battlefield at the funeral rhaenyra is a
mix of emotions she's just lost her
beloved mother brother and is left
feeling inadequate because she'll quote
never be a son to her father she'll
command cyrex to burn the pyre now you
might ask yourself where is viserys's
dragon and how come he didn't get to
burn the pyre viserys's dragon was
balerion we'll see the huge skull of
valerian later in the episode after the
dragon died of old age viserys never
bonded with another dragon hence why we
don't see him with one with the death of
the queen and would-be heir auto
convenes an emergency meeting with a
small council believing it of the utmost
importance to discuss secession in order
to avoid instability while otto is
thinking practically here he's failing
to consider the emotions of the king who
has just lost his wife and child
something that comes out in a great
performance here by patty considine
prince damon eavesdrops from a side room
as the members bicker over who should
secede and really it's down to two
people prince damon the next male in
line or rhaenyra the only living blood
of viserys if the king chose rhaenyra
he'd be going against a hundred years of
precedent it's basically a repeat of the
decision jaharis had to make female heir
with a better claim or male with a
weaker claim this time however instead
of convening a great council viserys
will make the decision on his own demon
does not believe his brother has
ambitions for the throne and at this
time cannot make the decision between
his brother and daughter but this will
soon change as otto hears word that the
night of the wife's funeral daemon was
in a brothel calling the king's dead son
the heir for a day celebrating his death
this will be what eventually sways
viserys to name his daughter as
successor and you gotta give a hand to
corliss here who's like hey my wife was
almost queen maybe we should consider
her again but that's quickly shot down
otto is seen sending a letter off to old
town where his house is from perhaps
it's news about the king or maybe
something more nefarious otto has called
in his daughter and wants her to keep
the king company during these sad times
but really what it looks like to me is a
ploy for his daughter to get close to a
king who is now without a queen he even
asks her to wear one of their mother's
pretty dresses in the book this may not
come across as abrupt and calculated as
alison had cared for viserys's
grandfather king jaharis in his final
years reading him books changing his
clothes and keeping him company here
however we can tell this whole thing
makes alison anxious we see her picking
at her nails something we saw her do at
the tournament in one of the king's
chambers he looks at what appears to be
his wife's ring hiding it before alison
arrives to keep him company in front of
him is a large model of what appears to
be old valyria a once great city that
was wiped out by a catastrophic volcanic
event known as the doom the targaryens
were the only major family of valyrian
dragonlords to survive this as they had
been on dragonstone at the time instead
of the continent of essos where the
cataclysm took place alicent tells the
king that when her mother died people
only spoke to her in riddles but what
she really wanted was someone just to
say sorry and she becomes the first
person to say sorry for viserys's loss
it's a nice little scene that sets up
more to come for these two after viserys
finds out about his brother celebrating
and toasting the air for a day he brings
him into the great hall to confront him
how could his brother betray him like
that viserys has been nothing but an
ally to him he's only ever defended him
but damon lets out his real feelings he
feels like he's been swept aside sent
away to the veil or the watch anywhere
but by his brother all he's wanted is to
be hand of the king something he feels
entitled to being his brother but
viserys has heard enough and orders his
brother to return to runestone to be
with his wife as damon leaves viserys
cuts himself yet again on the throne an
ill-fated omen in a show where anyone's
life could be ended at any moment
rhaenyra is brought to her father who
looks over the skeleton of his beloved
dragon valerian he asks his daughter an
important question what does she see
when she looks at a dragon to which she
replies i suppose i see us it just goes
to show the connection the targaryens
have with dragons a connection which has
the common folk equate them with gods
the king laments his ancestors use of
this power claiming that it's what
brought upon the doom over a century ago
however actual causes of the doom aren't
a hundred percent known and various
theories are out there but the most
important thing viserys tells his
daughter is the secret dream passed only
from king to king a dream from aegon the
conqueror himself called the song of ice
and fire which is also the name of the
game of thrones series in the stream the
king foresaw the end of the world
starting with a terrible winter gusting
from the north and on it a terrible
darkness that would destroy every living
thing when this darkness comes all of
westeros must be united if humanity is
to survive and a targaryen must be
seated on the throne to unite them this
of course is a reference to the
impending doom brought upon by the white
walkers in game of thrones viserys has
made the decision to name rhaenyra his
heir making her promise to carry this
secret as he does so he holds onto the
cat's paw dagger this is a dagger made
of valyrian steel and was seen all
throughout game of thrones it certainly
looks a lot like the dagger arya used to
kill the night king it's interesting
that viserys holds this dagger while
reciting this dream almost like the
dagger itself is a physical
manifestation of the promise each
targaryen king makes to one another to
keep the dream alive the dagger
therefore becomes both a warning and
reminder of the impending winter and
darkness to come it also becomes the
very thing that kills the darkness in
the great hall viserys has amassed the
lords of the realm to swear allegiance
to him and his newly appointed heir
rhaenyra highlighted are corliss
valerian hobart hightower borman
baratheon and rickenstark of winterfell
an ancestor of nedstar the episode ends
with renera the anointed heir and next
in line to become the queen of the andal
the rhoynar the first men lord of the
seven kingdoms and protector of the
realm now we get into a little book and
trailer spoiler section so if you don't
want to be spoiled throw your computer
out the window early on in the episode
rhaenyra's voiceover talks about the
only thing that could tear down the
house of the dragon was itself this
referring to the dance of the dragons
the civil war which will break out
pitting targaryen against targaryen
namely rhaenyra and her half-brother
aegon ii who hasn't even been born yet
aegon ii is the son of viserys and
alicent hightower the two will get even
closer after we saw them together in
this episode and mary starting a rift
between her and renera who seemed best
friends in the first episode it's king
viserys's death which it seems they're
setting up with this unhealable wound
that becomes the catalyst for this civil
war corliss valerian talks about prince
admiral the triarchy cragus drachar also
known as crab feeder this is a nod to
corliss and damon eventually teaming up
to take him on in the battle of the
stepstones we saw corliss taking damon's
side at almost every turn during the
meetings at the small council in what
may come as a shocking twist considering
the two were the top contenders to take
over the throne damon and renera marry
and go on to have three children
together their one daughter being named
visenya the same name ranira wanted to
call her mother's child should she have
had a daughter raenira's first marriage
however is with lenard valerian son of
corliss and renis who we see briefly at
the tournament we'll see an older
version of him in the trailer they'll go
on to have three children however it's
highly suspected the children aren't
lanors since it was rumored lenore was
gay and also that the kids had no
resembling features of their father like
his silver hair it looks like daemon
does not heed the king's orders and
takes messaria to dragonstone where he
has with him a dragon egg kristin cole
becomes a love interest for renera in
the book even becoming her devoted
knight however the book offers varying
accounts on why kristen ends up teaming
up with alice and tie tower it will be
really interesting which version the
show ends up depicting i love the show's
use of alison in a green dress here
foreshadowing the eventual split at
court between the factions the greens
and the blacks if you want a more
detailed version of that check out my
house of the dragon trailer breakdown
which i'll leave a link to in the
description we'll later see adult
allison to use that very cat's paw
dagger we saw viserys hold against
rhaenyra likely as vengeance for one of
ranira's kids cutting out the eye of one
of allison's i realize that it's getting
super late i'm writing and doing this as
the show comes out and the video is
getting way long so maybe next week i'll
actually end up doing two videos one
breakdown and one preview with spoilers
for the season to come if that sounds
like a good idea let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember i think i'll
take two chickens